we bought that for the neck because we
thought the neck could use them but we
didn't realize that it works sort of
ugly way of it she is not an attractive
she's honest right
yeah unfortunate John Koch err John Koch
antiques
I'm Kevin Creighton I'm the manager of
John Koch antiques we're an antique shop
on the Upper West Side they've been
having and we specialize in the set for
TV and movies we buy a state for the
most part so we get people's whole lives
we were sort of spilling out on the
floor and other dealers would come and
with them came the set decorators and
production designers that did the
television shows and movies the first of
which was probably Woody Allen Sex in
the City
the knick blacklist vinyl The Good Wife
madman Gotham wolf of Wall Street's Ugly
Betty Madam Secretary deuce with James
Franco Saturday Night Live I think we've
done almost every the ice storm
admissions girl on a train Gossip Girl
DB goes down other than that it's just
the people that come in that you really
surprised that like Lucy K and he
actually asked to use the stores
location for a season finale last year
and then the producer came over to me
said Louie wants to know I feel like
doing a favor and being the show I want
to get there for her okay which is 495
okay I don't want to get it I was
working on louis c.k shows it's just
like an honor you know I would do it for
free
we have cut that
Oh
was our first feature of Point Break did
we do that before rumors not officially
yet right so as a company tremors would
be the first technically the last future
gasps I don't know someone should Google
that are you going to ask us questions
or do you want us to start talking did
you introduce each other I would love to
I would like to introduce you to Tom
Woodruff jr. who is the co-founder of
amalgamated dynamics I'd like to
introduce you to Alec Gillis he's the
co-founder of Adi home of the
oscar-winning creature effects team when
people think of practical effects
creatures you think of non
computer-generated characters we've been
lucky to be involved with some of the
biggest and best of those types of
monsters we did the worms and tremors we
did the fat makeups of Tim Allen in the
Santa Clause all the practical animals
in Jumanji with done the alien we've
done the predator with our ship troopers
I wasn't done you can keep going buddy
and of course there's always the gorilla
cut right now that's perfect right now
we cut putting the gorilla costume we
started performing own creatures because
we both have his sort of observation of
stuntmen despite their talents and their
skills them going into a creature suit
and not really knowing how to make a
creature suit work it would be very
weird for us to just say we're going to
build something and then bring it to set
and say now what are you hungry that's
some foodie you hungry if you're a
digital animator you build the character
and you follow through and you make it
move and you bring it to life so that's
our philosophy is the final step is
performance because that's where it
lives you want to try a little tiny
piece here go ahead
what do you think you want some more you
hey hey yes listen listen I can get you
fresh bread
I can I can get you fresh bread tremors
is an example of a film that was from
the pre-digital era and if you look at
it the practical effects they've stood
the test of time and we're proud of that
digital effects can do things that we
can't possibly do practical effects have
a presence to them that even the best
CGI work gets close to but doesn't
completely achieve in other words
there's more emotion I believe to a
practical creature than to a digital
creature
wave to the camera and say goodbye bye
bye bye
he's so temperamental when we get pulled
over in the back cars luckily a lot of
the police officers just want their
picture taken with it yes sir you can
please do we've created the bat car for
the Michael Keaton Batman movie the
Mystery Machine from Scooby Doo
everything from Herbie the lovebug to
the land speeder from Star Wars we
create a lot of wild rods out of some
junk
in the past two or three years we've
created 1516 iconic movie cars I had a
real job at one time in a major airline
we initially started out refurbishing
old cars we decided we were going to
start making some iconic cars that you
could actually get in and out of it
drive it kids can climb on it and look
at it
typical bills can be anywhere from as
little as two weeks to as much as three
years the Speed Racer Mach 5 sitting
here beside us started off as a 94
Corvette hopefully here in about 30 days
it'll be finished up have a great big
honking M on the hood of it it'll look
awesome there's a tremendous amount of
trial and error a lot of these cars have
a lot of fiberglass on them it's a labor
of love come out and just continue
putting down layers and layers of
fiberglass you can't go to Oh Riley's
are at mast auto parts and asking for a
part for a back car our Eleanor from
Ghana 60-seconds car upfront is
absolutely a Screen Actors we can get it
from the stainless aluminum interior to
the seats to the shifter the go baby
switch in the center and we drive
Eleanor just like it's supposed to be
driven that's why it was built
everything we have we take out and drop
every single piece we take it all to the
local stores we go to McDonald's what
better thing to get throw shoes into the
back car
Oh
this story begins in California to be
more specific here in an unspecified
studio lot this is the story of a TV
producer a physicist and the man who
brought them both together that's Wendy
I'm one of the co producers of Marvel's
agent Carter in 2015 ABC released the
show agent Carter about a secret agent
working in the late 1940s in season two
they debuted a character named Jason
Wilkes Jason is a scientist who works at
isodyne energy and a science character
needs to sound like a real scientist
kind of like this
Peggy enters to find Howard the
chalkboard with books lambda is
intimately linked constant divided by MC
except we can't calculate them without
an accurate reading of your mass no mass
no wavelength so you need to write
science e dialogue write sciency stuff
on the chalkboard and have a science e
looking lab but you don't have any
science writers on staff no
unfortunately we do not so what did you
do we called our friends up at the
National Academy of Sciences I've
exchanged at Rick this is Rick hey I'm
Rick I work at the National Academy of
Sciences we connect scientists and
engineers with people in Hollywood
people like Wendy yeah we connected her
with Clifford hi my name is Clifford
Johnson I am a professor in the physics
and astronomy department at USC so it
goes like this
Rick pears Clifford with Wendy and they
work together to bring real science into
TV shows yeah uh yeah yeah for example I
got an email one time saying so how do
you build an atomic bomb and I had to
sort of help them with that it was a lot
of fun Rick's team has a database with a
lot of scientists in it over 2000 and
they've worked on some major blockbuster
films
Iron Man two and three The Avengers age
of Ultron at man vs. Superman star trek
into darkness
mission impossible five films a
narrative have been inspiring people
since the 19th century to go out and do
great things and build great things
we're not trying to be the accuracy
police we're not fact checkers per se
what our goal is is to inspire more
scientists characters and better science
in mainstream media projects and that's
the story about the hot line for
scientists in Hollywood that is changes
right popcorn movies a match made in
theatre heaven but there was a time when
this was banned
popcorn has been around for over 8000
years but when it hit American streets
in the mid-1800s it took off it was
cheap and could be mass-produced on the
go not to mention it smelled amazing
it was the go-to snack at circuses
sporting events and fairs in fact the
only place you wouldn't find popcorn was
at the movies you see going to the
movies used to be a major event the only
people that went were fancy rich folks
because you had to be educated enough to
read fancy like there was even a
coat-check but there was definitely no
concession stand there was however
popcorn street vendors who set up shop
outside theaters they made a killing
selling to waiting theater goers theater
goers that started smuggling their pop
treats inside not cool early movie
theaters kindly asked patrons check
their popcorn before entering then in
1927 film started adding sound meaning
everyone went to the movies the Great
Depression followed making movies a
cheap escape huge crowds plus crunch
muffled sound equals another revenue
opportunity for theater owners by 1945
over half the popcorn consumed in
America was being eaten at the movies a
marriage that has continued ever since
to get ourselves a treat